[Music]
let's go to ashley in boston hey ashley
what's going on
hi dr john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm doing all right i'm a little nervous
i'm very excited to talk to you
i'm super nervous too and i'm excited to
talk to you also so
we can be nervous together let's figure
it out what's up
so um i've been listening to your show
for a while
and i really haven't heard this question
get
brought up so i will just get right into
it
i am a mom of an eight-year-old daughter
and i have been married to my husband
for seven years he also has two children
who are not mine so we both have
children that we brought in
prior so we don't share any children
together
we've been together for seven years um
all the kids have
grown up together um both of his
children are actually
ten um they're six months apart so
they're from two different moms
um my daughter is also like i said from
a different dad
um and over the past seven years we've
really worked hard on
trying to basically create
this family for when we're together
as normal as possible whatever normal
means right
whatever that means in 2021 right um
and as the kids are getting older you
know
it's becoming i think just with the way
that things are so different now and
technology and different temptations i
mean
growing up as a kid is a lot different
than even when i grew up right
and i'm really struggling and my husband
and i are struggling
with the difference in households
and kind of that transition period of
when we get my step kids back
we share like a week on week off
schedule um with his kids
and you know the expectations at the
mom's households are a lot different
than ours yep
and it feels like you know we're kind of
more like
the rule household um we have
they have the party house in the twinkie
house and then the uh
fruits and vegetables house basically
yes
and boo fun ruiner ashley
and it's hard um because as a step mom
um you know i'm not their biological
moms their moms are
completely in their life and
you know we've had some really big ups
and downs with those relationships
um with the relationships with those
other moms
yes you know we've gone through some
legal stuff
with a different mom we've done just
different things and
and you know i have a pretty good
relationship
um with my stepson's mother i think
better than my stepdaughter's mom
um and it's caused a lot of strain i
think on my relationship
with the kids and trying to navigate
not resenting the kids for their moms or
not
comparing myself constantly to the other
moms
yeah i was going to ask you why do you
why do you compare yourself to those
moms
um because
i guess i'm always second guessing if
i'm doing it right if
you know because i'm not their
biological mom so every parent on planet
earth 100 of the time
second guesses whether they're doing it
right or not and those that don't second
guess
are usually insane like they
yeah they have this like this is the way
to do it and then those kids keep the
mental health association of america
afloat there's not a mental health
association but they keep all the
psychologists and family therapists
afloat for the next generation um
yeah comparison is is i mean you know
this that it just steals
your soul from you right um very much so
but usually when i com when i am
comparing myself to something
it's because a i'm not totally secure in
what i'm doing right whether it's like
about
exercise or diets or whatever i think i
haven't fully done the work to know
right where i stand on my values and
what i believe
and then um the other part is
this insecurity as though i have this
imaginary standard i'm trying to live
into some fantasy that doesn't exist
does that make sense yes
and i guess that's you know this is my
first time being a stepmom
i've been doing it for seven years so
are you doing a good job i'm
trying to no are you doing a good job
i think so try again are you doing a
good job
yes yes you are and so
yeah um you
y'all have just uh a fun
sound and i'm saying fun because i like
chaos that's just a thing i love
so you guys have a fun household right
you've got
three three was it three moms two dads
is that right yeah three moms two dads
and a merry-go-round
and y'all are trying not to get dizzy on
a merry-go-round and so that's always
going to be hard and at the same time
you're going to have more opportunity
for
adventure and vomiting and laughter
does that make sense it's all of it
right
it is and i think that's what i'm
struggling with most now
is that i think this constant comparison
or i guess even second guessing like
does that time really matter they don't
have
you know different bedtimes at mom and
dad's and
the transition period i think longer now
because it takes them a couple days to
like
reacclimate to what we're doing
or you know we have chores and we have
responsibilities and
you know extracurricular activities and
we always want the kids to be doing
different things but i you know some of
the other parents don't agree with that
and they don't share that same value
so then i start second guessing you know
which one's right and wrong and i feel
like
i'm more of like a military parent
almost like i'm
constantly worried about everything kind
of being perfect so that our
chaos isn't so crazy but then so let me
relieve you of that
maybe you're not going to do this
perfectly
you're not my two kids
me and their mom are
stable and that's the y'all aren't
stable you know it's
there's not all this chaos there's not
coming and going and dude we're screwing
it up
right so you're not gonna do it
perfectly one of the big challenges
um in blended families
is a the fantasy that we're gonna make
this just like
our fantasy about a regular family and
as you mentioned there's not really a
regular family
it's not that's not a thing it's just
kind of it's a sometimes a media
fabrication right
and then on top of the quote unquote
regular family
um the wife
the stepmom often is the one tasked with
pulling all these strings to make sure
this thing looks the way the fantasy is
supposed to look
does that make sense yes and
so my challenge to you is
is to absolutely let that go
because here's what's going to happen
having boundaries
is going to be annoying for any teenager
in any home
in of any shape size whatever
boundaries are hard especially for kids
they are wired to bang their heads up
against those boundaries
now and when they're toggling back and
forth week
off week on week off week on it's even
harder i'm not a huge fan of the week on
week off for this very reason it's hard
for a child to toggle back and forth
in a 14 15 11 12 those are children
right
your values are your values and as long
as you're continuing to get wisdom
not from a comparison but from people
that you trust
and as long as you and your husband are
communicating with each other
you don't have to apologize for your
values you don't have to apologize for
your expectations for the kids when
they're in your home you just don't
and you have to expect that they're not
going to like it
and your goal right now isn't for them
to like you
their goal what you're doing is raising
great grown-ups
great adults and my promise is if you
play a long game here
they will circle back and over time pick
up you'll see them adopt those things
into their life that you're teaching
so it feels militant to you it's
probably not
right it's probably not i think the
other thing that i'm struggling
with too is maybe because me and the
other moms don't share the same values
or the same
expectations i think sometimes for the
kids that i
tend to resent them or feel like well
why don't they care about the kids as
much as i do
or and that's hey that's a that's you
trying to
wallpaper over shame yeah
it's not real and listen all that's
gonna get you
is uh this a kinetic tension when the
kids are in your presence
and they're gonna start stepping away
for you not because your boundaries but
because you're a third rail
and you're gonna start asking those
questions hey well what about
and how about and they're gonna hear you
grumbling they're gonna see you roll
your eyes
and then suddenly you're gonna put them
in a position to
have to choose between this woman who my
dad loves so we clearly like her
or we pretend we don't but we do she
makes us safe she's got hard boundaries
but she
kind of doesn't approve of our moms and
i'm going to choose my mom
every time because i'm a child right
right
right absolutely right don't put
a child in a position to choose don't do
that
be really proud of the values you and
your husband have agreed on that's
awesome
be really firm in how much you love love
love those kids
never ever ever talk bad about their
their parents
their their birth moms and if you've got
to grit your teeth if you've got to go
talk to a counselor you need to go for a
walk then do that
but i'll tell you asking questions like
why don't they love as much as
i guarantee you those moms are saying
good look why can't they just
this woman just let my child have a good
time
why could they just finish the movie on
a school night for crying out loud why
can't they just get a cell phone for
right and so those things become
circular they're a
waste of your life and at some point
somebody told you that what the what you
believed what you
think wasn't good whether that was your
ex-husband whether that was your family
whether that was
wherever that came from then i hate that
for you
because your values are good they're
your values
right yeah and as long as they're
tethered to things that are
good and you know um
strong and they're in relationship with
our people man those are your values
so let me ask you this question what's
one thing you need to improve
and here's why i ask that um i often
okay i i often go compare go
go on a comparison hunt when i know i'm
not doing what i'm supposed to be doing
right i really get obsessive about other
people's workout programs when i've just
laid off for two weeks
i get really critical of the way
somebody looks in their shirt
or the way somebody's eating at lunch
when i've let my diet go
to crap right so i'll ask you
what's something that's surfaced over
the last year
that you're really getting
self-conscious about that's making you
go on
on the hunt for what other people are
doing wrong in their lives
um i think people said patience
i mean i think being a working mom
um on top of you and you come home and
everything's crazy and you're just
trying to get tasks done
and when things go out of that and um
you know i tend to use my patients and i
don't feel like i give the kids enough
of my attention when it's that time
and i know i've heard you talk about
that about dedicating
certain times you know you wear
different hats at different times and
um you know i think i'm just not
enjoying
everything feels like a task and i think
that's
you know part of this parenting journey
but it's
it's not fun anymore you know like even
when we
go to do stuff where it just always
feels like
everything's being complete or say i
mean just for instance say we're gonna
go
take the kids to the zoo and on the ride
up there one of them might talk about
the time they went to the zoo with their
mom and that's all they're talking about
the entire time
so that's what i mean by it never feels
good enough sometimes that no matter
what gift no matter what i say no matter
what i
do it's and i think the kids do that
automatically just because they're kids
and you want to talk about
fun things you did with your friends so
here's something important for you to
know i love that you just told me that
so number one
you just called yourself out right this
isn't fun anymore
this is hard running a blended family
managing all these different parents
trying to love
two ten-year-olds and a seven-year-old
is chaos
in the best of circumstances right
not to mention a messy circumstance like
you guys have okay
exhale through that you're in a season
it's like
it's like you walked outside in the
middle of winter and you just think i'm
gonna freeze to death because this is
never gonna warm up i promise it is
okay a great thing you can do for
yourself is to begin to think i'm gonna
default to relationships not tasks
what's the silliest thing we can do
right now or hey everybody in the house
i just got home from work
we're gonna have 15 minutes i'm gonna
bomb everybody with water balloons or
everybody we're gonna do a 15 minute
everybody clean up and then we're gonna
go do something
it's not fun for you it's not rest for
you but it is default to relationship
and my promise is on the back end of
that
you will feel better than coming home
and trying to
like crack a whip get everybody to do
their task make sure everything's
checked off and everything looks the way
it's supposed to quote unquote look
the second thing is is that very common
in blended families is this pressure
a 10 year old feels to not
abandon mom to not abandon dad wherever
they happen to be
and so when they go to the zoo with you
there is a part of them that is feels
like they are abandoning their birth mom
and so they have to surface that they
got to bring that up
so that they can let themselves know i
still value her even though i feel
really safe with this new woman ashley
even though i feel really excited to go
with her to the zoo
oh i want to make sure i'm not letting
go of mom
that makes sense that has nothing to do
with you and everything to do with a 10
year old feeling like their world's
coming apart
yeah and that's i think where i'm
struggling where i feel like i'm
having feelings towards the kids even
though i love them but it's
this constant like comparison
listen listen do you love those kids do
you love those kids
yes a lot i do
okay i believe you and so when you hear
them
talk about their birth moms the most
loving thing you can do is to say
you are so lucky to have a mom
that will take you to the zoo
you've got two moms taking you to the
zoo
the luckiest kid ever right
tell me about what you you and your mom
like to do at the zoo
lean into it and you completely let go
of that comparison
and if it drives you i want you not to
write a fence on this i want you to lean
completely into it
if you say hey everybody it's eight
o'clock it's bedtime and one of them
says
my mom lets me stay up till nine i want
you to say
all right in our house we've talked
about this once you go get in bed at
eight and then when i want you to go sit
by them
when you're going to read them a bedtime
story because it's good to read the kids
and say tell me about a nine o'clock
bedtime what's that like in your mom's
house
lean all the way into it right lean all
the way into it
don't make a kid choose between who
they're gonna love
let them know that both of them both
moms love them
a lot and expect it those conversations
those comparisons are not about you
they're about the kid
feeling like they're having to choose
and they're coming apart
right and you
look at the world that you're feeling
less than where are you
feeling shame where do you feel like
some of your relational stuff is in ash
right are you really busy at work and
you're coming home and your kids are
getting your second or third fruits
is your husband not participating in
some of this stuff you need to get his
lazy butt in there to help is there some
places where you have
in moments when things start rattling
you default to tasks and i wanted to
look this way
versus you know what i don't give a crap
we'll do the dishes tomorrow hey husband
you get your butt in here and do the
dishes
we're going to go outside and throw
grass at each i don't know what you're
going to do we're going outside kick
soccer ball around
because i'm going to default to
relationships first i think we've got
and
we've got an obsession with our
kitchen's got to look this way
our house has to look this way i gotta
finish these emails i've got i've got
i've gotta
and we're waiting till all these tasks
are done before we do relationship
and the tasks never get done which means
we never do relationship
and then we go comparison hunting and
then these things just turn into ash
they just melt right ashley i
love your question i love your heart the
answer's inside you
and i am super excited to hear what
happens when you transition to some of
these new
new ways of doing things default
relationships over tasks
and start leaning really into those
those comparisons
lean way into them and see if your kids
don't
exhale you become a safe space they can
talk about
how cool their other mom is their other
house is
you become a safety said i know it's
hard if you need to find someone to talk
to find someone to talk to
don't let comparison steal your soul